we start with that breaking news and
skinnies understands a commercial
submersible has gone missing near the
site of the wreck of the Titanic it's
being reported this afternoon that the
vessel was used to take tourists to view
the wreck and certain rescue mission is
now underway with a famous shipwreck
sits nearly 4 000 meters at the bottom
of the Atlantic it's around 600
kilometers off the coast of Newfoundland
in Canada after its Discovery in 1985
the wreck has been extensively explored
by divers and submarine crews
okay well we're getting new details in
all the time about this story let's
bring our us correspondent James
Matthews who's monitoring the situation
uh for us from Washington
um and James from what we know about
this commercial submarine we don't know
if anyone was on board or not at the
moment but this is a a tourist type
vehicle is that right
uh yeah Sarah Jane used for tourism also
used for scientific research it costs a
lot of money for those who who take that
Journey which takes several hours you
know as you as you saw on that map it is
quite a distance off the coast of
Newfoundland uh it cost tens of
thousands of dollars to secure a place
on this particular submarine we've been
speaking to people who know the industry
who know the people involved in that
submarine struck tourism struck
scientific industry of the Atlantic
coast and they're telling us that the
The Vessel involved is a owned by a U.S
company it is a commercial submarine we
don't know how many people were on board
or are on board indeed but it has space
for a pilot stroke owner and for
passengers so quite small now the way
these things operate is that they pin
ping back a message every 15 minutes to
let everyone are sure know that things
are going well and that everybody on
board is safe it's our understanding
that those pings have not been heard
from this vessel for more than seven
hours and that is what is creating
serious concern and is what has prompted
this search operation coordinated for
now by the Boston Coast Guard but also
involving navies from Canada the United
States it's our understanding that UK
Navy has also involved in this search
there are things called drop weights
attached to this vessel Sarah Jane now
after 24 hours of no activity of no
messaging we understand that these
weights will lift off the submersible
enabling it to float to the surface and
that will happen assuming there has been
no catastrophic failure on board or a
reason why it can't float to the surface
such as whether it's been entangled or
not so that's the next thing that
Rescuers are waiting for and indeed
looking for that kicks in after 24 hours
the dropping of these weights and so and
my understanding is that that 24 hour
period will be up fairly shortly there
are provisions on board for survival
oxygen and also clothing for those on
board given the given the temperatures
at that depth you know four thousand
meters under the surface of the Atlantic
those Provisions that Survival equipment
is designed to last for 96 hours
in terms of a rescue operation it is
very difficult I mean given the depth
and given the currents at that
particular location it would be very
difficult well now impossible for for a
military submarine for example to get
there and to rescue those on board so it
is very difficult indeed to to see how
this situation might unfold should there
have been some kind of failure on board
that vessel but clearly that is yet to
be confirmed we don't know the
circumstances of it not having pained a
safety message for more than seven hours
we don't know how many people are on
board we do understand it is owned by a
U.S organization that as we say operates
tours for tourists and also for
scientists involved in research you know
it does have that attraction often a
Fatal Attraction the the Titanic which
sunk of course on its mid Voyage in 1912
it's first voyage after leaving
Southampton so
there are many questions at this stage
yet to be answered but serious concern
for that vessel and for those who are on
board
yeah really concerning indeed James
thank you James Matthews continuing to
monitor the situation for us from
Washington we'll bring you any updates
as and when we get them let's bring in
now former NATO and Naval Commander
Chris Parry thank you for um jumping on
to speak to us uh so promptly this is
breaking news very much a developing
story at the moment but your initial
concerns after hearing this news this is
a commercial Submarine that's simply
stopped contact with bass heading
towards the Titanic
yes it's very concerning indeed and
having listened to the time scale uh
it's very worrying uh I mean there's an
optimistic option and that is that
either lost an umbilical communication
with the surface uh or indeed uh there's
been a malfunction uh and the submarine
is continuing to operate but obviously
out of contact with its Mothership
um obviously at the other end of the
scale there could have been an accident
it could have been come entangled in the
wreckage of Titanic it could indeed have
had a catastrophic failure uh the answer
is we don't know just yet uh what we do
know of course it's uh the wreck site is
off the grand Banks it's a long way from
anywhere and the nearest rescue
facilities will be on the east coast of
the United States yeah just talk to me
about how difficult this search and
rescue operation will be it's been
conducted by Boston's Coast Guard
but you know they probably won't be used
to dealing with this kind of situation
we're talking about a vessel that will
be some way below the surface just how
difficult is it to not just find it but
then access it
you're quite right series uh Sarah Jane
it's a very difficult operation
um the actual nature of the seabed is uh
very undulating Titanic herself lies uh
in a trench there's lots of debris
around uh so trying to differentiate
with sonar in particular uh and trying
to Target the area you want to search in
with another submersible it's going to
be very difficult indeed
um the only sort of uh hope I think one
has is that the mothership will have a
standby craft uh that can actually go
down and investigate immediately and see
what's going on
take though
well I would hope that any responsible
organization would have another
submersible ready at under an hour's
notice to go down and see what's
happened particularly with a commercial
organization like this I'm afraid if
we're talking about a uh an operation
from the east coast of the states uh I
would think anything up to a couple of
days to actually get there before they
can even start looking
yeah
um you know this submarine will be some
distance from the coast and some
distance below the surface of the water
and you know these types of vessels well
what kind of facilities are there on
board to kick in when an emergency
arises no matter what that might be
well they're pretty basic I'm afraid to
say I mean when we think of a submarine
we think of a big submarine that we're
used to with our military forces this is
essentially a submersible a Leisure
craft if you like it'll have some spare
air and some in compressed bottles and
things like that which will enable it to
do an emergency surfacing and also keep
the occupants alive for some time but
it'll only last for so long and the
longer this goes on of course the more
at risk the people inside that
submersible are
oh Chris um I hate to ask this question
but what time frame are we operating in
well um as I said I hope that somebody
would have sent something down already
either an unmanned uh submersible or one
that's manned to see what's going on I'm
afraid the dirt and information that
we've had from the commercial
organization suggests that they don't
know what's happened and I'm afraid to
say that we uh we need to wait for more
information before we can speculate but
it's not looking good